saluant ce jour des astuces nous avons
parlé de créativité cette astuce pour
booster stimuler votre créativité quand
vous avez un projet à faire que ce soit
artistique personnelle ou
professionnelle il faut déjà distingué
la créativité de l'imagination c'est pas
parce qu'on doit créer quelque chose
qu'on ne doit avoir nécessairement un
maximum d'imagination l'imagination
c'est ce qui n'existe pas la création
c'est ce qui existe donc on peut tous
créer quelque chose et ça c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle première astuce il
faut passer la peur de l'échec ne vous
jugez pas de ce que vous produisez comme
création il sera toujours temps de
l'améliorer soyez dans un état d'esprit
positif ne jugez pas votre propre
travail
laissez le venir comme il vient brut il
ya d'abord la création d'une première
matière et c'est cette matière là qu'on
va retravailler après si on cherche à
atteindre la perfection dès le départ on
se juger en fait on se bridant la
créativité deuxième astuces noter vos
idées ça paraît évident mais ça l'est
pas forcément tu es que vous avez une
idée quelconque qui viennent sur ce que
vous travaillez en ce moment où pas noté
l'a sur téléphone portable dans un
carnet où vous voulez mais ne la
laissait pas filer vous pensez que vous
vous en souviendrez le jour vous en
aurez besoin c'est complètement faux
vous n'oublierez disent ils à noter tout
ce qui vous paraît utile et encore plus
ce qui vous paraît inutile ce qui est
inutile aujourd'hui sera peut-être utile
demain troisième astuces quand vous êtes
en pleine phase de création sur un sujet
défini clé une vraie volonté d'aller
dans ce sens là si vous bloquez ou si
vous voulez vous stimulez différemment
changer de lieu de travail
ça fonctionne très très bien d'aller
dans un autre endroit ne serait ce que
dans un café avec son ordinateur chez
quelqu'un d'autre en vacances ailleurs
quelque chose qui fonctionne bien sur
moi par exemple c'est d'aller dans un
espace de coworking je fais la même
chose qu'ici au bureau chez moi mais je
suis stimuler différemment quatrime
astuces élites et de vous embourber dans
une mauvaise direction c'est-à-dire
autant faut pas juger autant si vous
prenez un axe une direction et que rien
ne vient au bout d'un jour deux jours
que vous voyez qu'ils avaient une bonne
idée de base mais qu'elle n'est pas
vraiment exploitable en fait qui a rien
qui se lit ça ça arrive on a une bonne
idée sur un truc mais en même temps
cette bonne idée ça à la fois le frein
de tout le reste dans ces cas là vous
pouvez aussi essayer de passer à autre
chose seth godin disait par rapport à la
créativité échoué échoué rapidement
échoué souvent c'est tout à fait l'idée
ne pas hésiter aussi de passer une idée
à une autre et de pas s'enliser dans un
espèce de bourbier dans lequel on
n'arrive pas à s'en sortir
5e astuces qui fonctionne très bien
aussi des zooms et est resté un maximum
dans le four rester dans le lointain si
vous devez travailler sur un sujet
spécifique ne pensait pas ce sujet
spécifique penser à une espèce de
globalité pour écrire des choses ou
réfléchir des choses qui n'ont pas un
gros lien direct avec le focus initiale
le fait de dézoomer
va permettre d'amener des idées qui
peut-être n'ont pas un vrai sens au
départ sur ce que vous essayez de créer
mais qui vont apporter quelque chose et
qui vont surtout vous apporter une autre
mécanique mental un bon exercice pour ça
c'est le brainstorming qui se fasse tout
seul ou à plusieurs mois quand je dois
faire un brainstorming tout seul
j'utilise les my mac les cartes mentales
dont on a parlé plein de fois sur cette
chaîne et à plusieurs le prennent
storming ça fonctionne merveilleusement
bien si vous voulez je vous ferai un
jour un master class sur le
brainstorming dites le moi dans les
commentaires si ça vous tente
6e astuces sur laquelle je veux pas
m'attarder parce que j'ai fait une vidéo
là dessus c'est de sortir de sa zone de
confort ça va vous nourrir en créativité
en rencontrant des nouvelles personnes
en allant voir un spectacle en faisant
une activité dont vous n'avez pas
l'habitude ces expériences là vont
nourrir votre créativité vous vous
apporter des points de vue différents
quel que soit le sujet sur lequel vous
travaillez en ce moment hier par exemple
j'ai fait une vidéo avec sur l'est de la
chaîne je suis modeste c'est pas du tout
ma zone de confort les chaînes beauty
mais c'était intéressant et ça m'a donné
plein d'idées pour la suite et enfin la
septième et dernière astuce qui est
peut-être une des plus essentielles avec
le brainstorming et le fait de noter ses
idées bon en fait je suis en train de
vous dire qu'elles sont tout aussi
importantes mais je crois que ce soit de
temps en temps abordez votre création ou
votre problématique de création d'une
manière générale comme si ce n'était pas
la vôtre comme si c'était pas pour vous
une fois qu'on se désemplit du projet on
a un meilleur regard dessus
c'est pour ça qu'on est toujours très
bon à donner des conseils aux autres
avoir un point de vue objectif sur les
autres alors donnez souvent des très
très bons conseils tels que soi-même
l'action qui sont en train de faire on a
toujours un point de vue très pertinent
c'est assez étonnant qu'on n'arrive pas
à le retrouver pour nous et la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on peut le retrouver
il faut pu imaginer le lien qui relie le
projet à vous et regardez ça comme si
c'était un pote à vous qui vous
présentait il ya une bonne technique
aussi c'est de donner tout le projet un
pote à un allié ou quelqu'un de la
famille qui l'étudient qu'il le
comprenne laissé passer deux trois jours
et après il vient vous le vend très bien
vous l'exposer et vous le regardez et
vous l'écoutez comme s'il parlait de sa
création à nos créations au sens large
ça peut être un projet de vie ça peut
être un projet artistique ça peut être
écrire un bouquin faire une musique
monte une société crée un nouveau
produit par le mot création j'entends le
mot développer une idée quelle que soit
voilà pour ces cet asus mercredi puisque
le mercredi c'est le jour des astuces ou
je vous donne des astuces j'espère que
cette vidéo vous a plu merci de l'avoir
regardé si vous avez aimé n'hésitez pas
à me le faire savoir en laissant une
petite création personnelle de votre
part nous allons dire un petit pouce en
l'air par exemple vous pouvez également
commenter je lis tous les commentaires
j'en rate
15 histoire de vous tirer un petit peu
demain on parlera de l'expérience de
milton samedi lors un master class sur
la lecture rapide puisque vous l'avez
demandé
vendredi je mentalise terrine trash et
dimanche prochain je vous explique un
tour pour bluffer d'autres personnes
mais comme on en a parlé déjà depuis
quelques semaines vous ferez la démo
d'abord de ce tour sur quelqu'un avant
de vous l'expliquer comme ça vous aurez
la démonstration en plus aller n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner avant de partir
puisque le mental blog c'est une vidéo
par jour pendant un an
rendez vous demain à 17h ciao